this was a swift precise military strike
that has huge unpredictable and possibly
long-term consequences the target was
one of Iran's most senior leaders Qasem
Soleimani was in a convoy Baghdad
Airport when it was struck by three
American missiles in the middle of the
night his death will send shockwaves
through the Middle East Iran is now
threatening a violent retaliation
this temporary joy of the Americans and
the Israelis will not last long before
it turns to grief the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard Corps the people of
Iran and the front of resistance
throughout the geographic latitude of
the Islamic world will take revenge of
this proud martyr a Pentagon statement
made clear that it was president Trump
who gave the order for the assassination
a pentagon statement made clear that it
was President Trump who gave the order
for the assassination and why general
Soleimani was actively developing plans
to attack American diplomats and
servicemembers in Iraq and throughout
the region it said general Soleimani and
his goods force were responsible for the
deaths of hundreds of American and
coalition servicemembers and the
wounding of thousands more president
Trump normally so expressive on Twitter
posted a simple image of the Stars and
Stripes without any comment the US
Embassy in Baghdad has this morning
urged all US citizens to leave Iraq
immediately this was an act of war the
Americans assassinated a senior Iranian
military official a person who was a war
hero in Iran and also a person who
helped save Iraq and Syria from Isis and
the same is true in Iraq the Iraqis will
also be seeing this as an act of war
against Iraq because the Americans also
assassinated a senior Iraqi war hero and
commander that works under the Iraqi
Prime Minister so there will be severe
consequences
the assassination comes days after
protesters in Baghdad attacked that
embassy the violence was triggered by US
airstrikes on the Iraqi border was
killed two dozen Iranian militia in
response hundreds of extra American
troops were sent to Iraq and President
Trump promised to retaliate if necessary
Washington believes the Iran is severely
weakened through harsh sanctions and
this will harm them further still
last night's strike where the planned or
opportunistic would have been calculated
with that in mind
Iran's response might not be immediate
but a response of some kind is all but
guaranteed Alister Bunko Sky News